Cause everything does accelerate,
things constantly move forward and become more and more,
um,
more and more integrated into our life experience.
And I wonder what is the next stage?
This if,
I mean like the,
the secular trends and you look at technology and you look at technologies like
blockchain for instance.
And I think,
you know,
we're,
we're moving to a world where anything created exists forever.
Um,
that there's no centralized control over who sees what,
um,
that,
uh,
you know,
these,
these models become completely de centralized and all these barriers,
um,
that we,
that exist today aren't as important anymore.
What do you think of something like Gab?
Gab seems to be a response to the fact that some people are getting banned from
other platforms and they're just allowing anybody to come on say anything they
want.
The downside of that is of course the most horrible people are going to be able
to say anything they want with no repercussions.
The good side is anybody can say whatever they want.
Yeah.
I haven't studied them too much,
but I do know that they have taken action on accounts as well.
They have suspended accounts and they,
if they have a terms of service as well,
what did they suspended accounts for?
And I dunno,
it's,
it's probably conduct related.
It's probably,
it might be doxing,
you know?
Um,
probably right.
But it's just a,
it's just a question of like,
you know,
the rules and if you agree to the rules,
then you know,
you sign up for the service and if not,
there will be other services.
But like,
it,
I,
you look at,
you look at the trends and I think,
um,
you know,
certainly things become a lot more public and certainly things become a lot more
open.
Certainly the,
the,
the barriers and the boundaries that we have in place today become less
meaningful.
And I think there's a lot of positives in that.
And I,
I also think there's a lot of danger that we need to be mindful of.